j'ai essayé la nouvelle Audi Q8 i Tron
100% électrique voiture de dingue 408
chevaux ça roule du feu de Dieu pour le
même emmené sur les chemins et en plus
de ça vous avez jusqu'à 532 km
d'autonomie sur le modèle SUV c'est le
modèle que j'ai ici et le truc sur
lequel a vraiment bossé Audi c'est la
recharge on va passer d'une vitesse
maximale de 150 kg jusqu'à 170 qui fait
que vous la recharger jusqu'à à peu près
80 % en seulement 30 minutes c'est
d'ailleurs la toute première
Q8 électrique avec un design qui a été
un peu revu repensé qui est extrêmement
agressif sur le modèle Sportback les
suspensions sont vraiment hyper smooth
on a l'impression de rouler sur du coton
après ce qui est un peu moins
confortable c'est le prix on est un
petit peu moins de 100000 euros mais
c'est pas une voiture qui est en
destinée aux particuliers mais plus au
flotte d'entreprise pour des cadres
dirigeants autant aux dinosaures des Q8
et Q8 ici mais ça sert surtout avant de
plus de voitures dans l'entrée milieu de
gamme même si ça reste un secteur
extrêmement premium sur des voitures
très belles très belles finition on a
vraiment une voiture qui est super top
alors est-ce qu'elle vous intéresse
est-ce qu'elle vous plaît est-ce que
vous avez déjà eu une voiture de Audi et
est-ce qu'on voyant c'est Q8 i Tron et
bien vous avez envie d'aller dans
l'univers Audi marquez moi ça dans les
commentaires